>> Laura: SOVIET DICTATOR
JOSEPH STALIN KNEW HOW TO
GET RID OF HISTORY HE DIDN'T
LIKE.
HE JUST ERASED IT.
THAT'S ONE HISTORY LESSON
THE LEFT HAS LEARNED VERY
WELL.
THE OBSESSION WITH SCRUBBING
AMERICA'S PAST IS AN
OVERDRIVE.
THIS TIME EVEN IN TEXAS.
THE DALLAS SCHOOL BOARD
VOTED YESTERDAY TO CHANGE
THE NAMES OF THREE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS NAMED
AFTER CONFEDERATE GENERALS.
ROBERT E. LEE.
STONEWALL JACKSON AND
WILLIAM.
AND/OR WELLIAN USE OF DOUBLE
SPEAK.
ONE SCHOOL TRUSTEE SAID
DROPPING THE NAMES WAS
NEEDED IN ORDER TO
ACKNOWLEDGE HISTORY.
NO, REPLACING HISTORICAL
NAMES AND TOPPLING STATUES
ISN'T ACKNOWLEDGING HISTORY
OBVIOUSLY IT'S ERASING IT
JUST NEVER EXISTED?
WHY DO THAT?
WELL, OF COURSE, SLAVERY WE
ALL KNOW WAS ABOMINABLE AND
EESM.
WHAT DO WE LEARN ABOUT THE
PAST BY FORGETTING THE PAST?